and where's the fourth musketeer where's
samantha oh um
she's no longer with us
yeah so kim cattrall may not be
reprising her role as samantha jones in
the sex and the city revival series and
just like that
i personally feel very pleased with how
we've handled it but she is enjoying
some of the online commentary about her
character's absence from the show will
fans be given a satisfying storyline as
to her whereabouts i mean i can't speak
for the audience they have to have that
experience themselves the new series
which stars sarah jessica parker as
carrie cynthia nixon as miranda and
kristen davis as charlotte addressed
sam's absence almost immediately in the
premiere episode
i told her that because of you know what
the book business is now it just didn't
make sense for me to keep her on as a
publicist she said fine and then fired
me as a friend she didn't fire you
okay she stopped returning my calls look
i understand that she was upset but i
thought i was more to her than an atm
you are
she was embarrassed so embarrassed she
took a job and moved to london
so we don't know if kim has watched the
series but she does seem to be enjoying
the fan's reactions liking several
messages on twitter including one that
reads quote kim cattrall didn't return
to sex in the city because her scatting
career is finally taking off a nod to
this viral video making music with her
now ex-husband mark levinson
yeah
bo said for cable window latin he quote
and another that gushed quote and just
like that i find myself only wanting to
watch anything kim cattrall is in this
is a kim appreciation tweet
you know for me i i feel that the most
important thing is always do we have
something left to say
because i think at my age which i am
grateful for which i am still learning
embracing is
time
and how do i want to spend the time do i
want to spend it doing something that
i've explored to the fullest
of course kim has made it clear that she
has no intentions of returning to the
franchise after the release of the 2010
film sex in the city 2. and at the
show's premiere last week show runner
michael patrick king opened up to e.t
about doing the show without her we knew
kim wasn't going to do the series
because she had for her reasons finished
playing samantha so then it was the
beginning point rather than ignore it we
decided to make it part of the story and
we did everything we could to honor
samantha who we love the character and
we know the fans love
no one could be another samantha
as for kim she seems to be thriving
sharing pics of her getaway to italy on
instagram
what we needed three single gals back on
tap
but the question remains could kim still
make a return when eti spoke with
cynthia she said fans probably shouldn't
hold their breath i think that kim has
made it really clear that she's done and
we've heard her and
but i think that i think yeah i think we
deal with it really well i think and
really really creatively
but when we asked kristen if the door is
open she had this to say
it is not up to me i don't want that
pressure who is it up to michael patrick
king and i guess hbo max maybe
um
you know i believe michael patrick and
sarah are are are on the record as
saying that and just like that was
conceived with the three of us
um and our new friends we have four new
amazing intelligent fascinating
actresses who have joined us
and
um that's how the show was envisioned so
i i i don't know even how that would go
down but luckily like i said i don't
have to decide
[Music]